[Musique]
la nuit est comme un grand manteau noir
qui se poserait sur le jour pour nous
permettre de reposer nos yeux et nos
esprits enfin en principe
car pendant nos abandons sommeil
certains versent ont fait le choix de
traverser la nuit éveillés et de
travailler voici quelques-uns d'entre
eux à taxi un ambulancier
un chauffeur routier à gendarmes c'est
long surtout quand il ya rien à faire
quand ya peu de clients apprécient nom
continue boulot ça ça passe assez et
nous avec
avec car en fait on travaille on fait
que des dégâts départementale donc on
est on fait que du 15
la nuit est arrivé comme ça en fait
j'étais à la base je faisais de la
journée et en poissons en arrivant dans
cette boîte
je suis maintenant où on faisait de la
nuit ça m'a bien plu
c'est une autre ambiance moins de
véhicules moins deux personnes du coup
tout ce qu'on voit on ça attire notre
attention
22 heures place de la gare à tour
pluie intermittente froid saisissant les
taxis sont en attente
la file indienne c'est chacun son tour
premier arrivé premier servi
en attente d'un prochain voyage ou d'une
prochaine course destination inconnue
prêt à transporter n'importe qui à
chaque fois c'est une rencontre éphémère
à huit clos dans la chaleur d'une
limousine
parmi eux vincent 32 ans lui il ne
travaille que la nuit
moi mon choix premiers mois c'est la
circulation la circulation qui est
vachement fluide là comme la une course
de fond à mettre 10 minutes là en pleine
nuit la journée on peut mettre 45
minutes ou une heure ça c'est mon
principe pas le choix après il ya le
tarif aussi qu'un peu plus avantageux la
nuit c'est pas le même tarif que la
journée après les désavantages avec la
clientèle qui peut être compliqué la
fatigue aussi
une fois qu'on a goûté la nuit et la
circulation c'est difficile de revenir
le jour la nuit tout est différent
il ya aussi la détresse sa solitude et
une clientèle parfois ingérable mais
fois c'est chaud quand une équipe bien
éméché qui cherche la merde redire c'est
pas évident à gérer
il ya quelques hommes c'est compliqué à
gérer parfois le client est malade et
répand son mal-être sur la banquette
arrière
mais certaines nuits avec le passager
d'un soir ils partiront pour un long
trajet qui favorise les changes
la route pour lui c'est un plaisir une
passion pour l'automobile à la base ce
que je suis mécanicien auto de formation
fait rêver mon voisin qui était taxi et
qui m'a motivé à faire ça ça me plaisait
moi j'ai toujours aimé automobile ma
première passion c'est le compte bien la
nuit laisse son lot de mauvais de bons
souvenirs et parfois le destin ça vite
mon meilleur souvenir c'est d'avoir
rencontré ma femme dans le textile
l'avoir accusé d'avoir eu des enfants
avec elle c'est mon meilleur souvenir
merci beaucoup merci à vous
merci un jour sans doute vincent
arrêtera la nuit et gardera dans sa
mémoire des milliers de visages entrevue
dans la pénombre
[Musique]
la nuit c'est aussi des moments de
détresse d'urgence et l'obscurité donne
une gravité supplémentaires
[Musique]
karl et laurent sont ambulanciers pour
le salon tout commence ici dans leur qg
le régulateur des urgences déclencheur
intervention car les laurent passent la
nuit en montée et descente d'adrénaline
tant qu'on n'est pas sur place ont
jamais surprendre
quelle place et
toujours avoir des surprises
sacré internet
leur complicité est incroyable un duo
sous des professionnels c'est sûr mais
surtout plein d'une humanité rare
laissant le stress dans leur poche et
pourtant les situations sont parfois
dramatiques
savage arrive à le gérer
après la détresse y en a pas tout le
temps dire que les interventions c'est
pas que l'agro est restée fois
malheureusement c'est aussi la bobologie
mais bon on est obligé de se déplacer on
est missionné donc on le fait on évite
d'avoir trop de jugement déjà deux par
rapport à l'intervention s'est
s'inquiété moment c'est vraiment des des
petits doigts coupés quoi mais oui on
essaie d'être aussi projet regarder des
personnes trois chercheurs tout
simplement
[Musique]
chaque intervention est une histoire
différente une tranche de vie
ambulanciers de nuit c'est un choix pour
ces deux hommes
mais pour karl ce n'est pas un hasard il
se trouve que j'ai abordé pour la
première fois ce métier en étant sur le
brancard moi même parce que je m'étais
blessé et je me cherchais un petit peu à
l'époque en fait en discutant avec
l'ambulancier qui était près de moi j'ai
pas il a dû déclencher quelque chose
peut-être là la fibre pour ce métier
depuis bas j'ai essayé j'ai mis un
premier pied dedans et j'ai vu que ça me
plaît c'est bien mais j'ai décidé de
poitiers
généralement ils sont les premiers à
intervenir les premiers réconforter à
écouter car les laurent sont deux amis
et son polyvalent selon les
interventions l'un prend le volant
l'autre accompagne malades souvent ils
se parlent ils en ont besoin pour
accepter la brutalité parfois du
quotidien discret mais attentif
chaque intervention est une nouvelle
histoire dans laquelle ils se sentent
utiles et toujours avec cette
gentillesse inaltérable
2h30 sur procession des rameaux
il a choisi chicago pour faire ses
adieux
[Musique]
22h30 en banlieue nord de paris deux
semi remorques sont prêts à partir pour
une livraison de jean-baptise vient de
se lever l'état de 30 ans mais à 18 ans
il avait déjà tous les permis poids
lourd pour avaler chaque soir
le ruban de soie
[Musique]
départ pour château la vallière en indre
et loire quatre heures de route
c'est une vie de solitaire certes mais
la solidarité des routiers n'est pas une
légende on vit tous la même choses ont
commencé voilà sur la route c'est pas
toujours facile surtout en camion quoi
donc faut être très solitaire et aimer
la nuit c'est sûr mais là comme la halle
à paris la nuit c'est comme du bonheur
il ya personne sur la route 5 nuits par
semaine jean mathis et au volant sa
cabine si sa deuxième maison
mais surtout sa bulle si votre vie quoi
ça lance allant vers les autres comme
d'usagé des copains qui mise à nu c'est
fait pour dormir bayadh a fait qu'on
voulait sykes mais c'est ça c'est fait
bien moi j'aime bien moins ce temps là
j'ai 30 ans pour un coût c'est que je
crois
des heures entières à être attentifs à
cette route changeantes surprenantes
parfois où tout peut surgir de
l'obscurité
mais jamais le silence on écoute la
radio donc après on pense pas forcément
à quelque chose ça peut être n'importe
quoi ça sert on se compte aussi faire
penser à autre chose qui va arriver dans
le week-end machin falcon et beaucoup
pensent y fait
[Musique]
3 heures du matin château la vallière
c'est le terminus mais pas pour ce soir
il lui reste encore tracter une autre
remorque à tours puis reprendre la
direction paris
pas de place pour une femme pour
l'instant dans la vie de jean baptiste
sa compagne à lui est faite d'asphalt et
du courbe à lhassa blement changeantes
[Musique]
en partant du principe que la nuit tous
les chats sont gris
certains y apporte quelques nuances des
hommes et des femmes veille aussi sur
notre sommeil
ils sont habillés de bleu vincent
patrick était au fond partie du psig le
peloton de surveillance et
d'intervention de la gendarmerie
[Musique]
là on a tourné la un petit peu moi on a
deux trois énergumènes qu'on connaît
bien
ouais mais il fait 0 degré on est en
semaine et plus personne
la nuit leur domaine ils interviennent
en renfort si besoin
ce n'est pas la délinquance routière
leurs objectifs mais les vols agressions
et trafics en tous genres
les rondes sont précises avec des
endroits plus tendue que d'autres
renforts sur un contrôle routier à
rendez-vous la moins de véhicules moins
deux personnes du coup tout ce qu'on
voit ans attire notre attention
autant les véhicules que les personnes
évidemment on voit plus de véhicules et
du coup on est beaucoup plus attentifs
surveillance silencieuse des maisons des
entrepôts des usines zone commerciale
mais parfois ils interviennent dans un
conflit familial ou pour calmer la d13
une victime le psig et d'une unité
spéciale de la gendarmerie
théo est l'équipier de vincent et de
patrick il a 18 ans il est volontaire
en fin d'école donc choisi un petit je
savais qu'il y avait des missions de
nuit et c'était ce côté là qui
m'intéressait côté intervention aussi au
lycée une vocation
j'ai de la famille en gendarmerie donc
c'est surtout ça qui m'a donné envie par
rapport à leur expérience et puis
surtout le côté le côté qui bouge
le gendarme âgé et surtout en huit ans
la nuit la nuit où tout semble presque
invisibles et pourtant ils analysent
chaque comportement sécurisé
il a surtout combien ils peuvent être
essentiel lorsque la nuit paisible
dessin devient parfois un réel cauchemar
pour les autres
nombreux sont ceux qui travaillent la
nuit dans des secteurs très différents
et souvent par choix
fasciné par la nuit dans une ambiance en
marge du quotidien souvent les mots des
écrivains rendent hommage à cette nuit
la nuit toute chose prend sa forme et
son véritable aspect c'est la nuit qu'il
est beau de croire à la lumière
seul d'obscurité a le pouvoir d'ouvrir
au monde
le coeur d'un homme
[Musique]
oh